A terry is celebrating like the others I told
him in the hardware and now it's in fashion
there is his terror a new one of the
good cow with the ball more and the nasa
well my what a shark imagines in the
pleasant a fence alone shows it outside  the
hostel
[Music]
hello my name is esther in 2015 I
joined the team that coordinated
the refugee relocation program
of the european union we
all work together to support
the member states most affected by
the migration crisis and to help
people who  They were fleeing from terrible
conflicts to find a refuge in
Europe. My name is the area, maybe I am the
Uich and contribute to the implementation
of the program. I direct what actions but
enjoy the full. The European Union
called with Ming and acquires asylum and
right.  There is a
country and diversity, it is the European final and
in a safe and legal way, fill me in
for it, it is involved and 70 px, kind 10,
but he does not tell me, Sandro, promote justice,
asylum, my mother is from crime and
territorial of the police fund, and support standing
up to support me,
organization
look at how they wanted to be three that
required without sudden
contraction of the apartment on the iphone
establish the family
[Music]
will require electric charge in
teleconference the most different to
driving fix the mistress in fine
lines and the mood of semen and tobacco the
consul  german ms europe can put
ivima sofia and in her neck and valina in
the chances of ian walker and exhaled
enhance more than the strength well it is
creative to choose for the actions and
they were as he decided to admonish things
end up last besides he had
a lot to go up to the netherlands  with susana
good good in one and others go up good
me moon
[Music]
let's go straight
strong
I came from the car
every tweet everyone the report
[Music]